with five days left till the midterm
elections Joe Biden keeps stepping on
political rakes in a Shameless play to
buy votes Joe Biden is announcing that
senior citizens will be receiving an
historic raise in their Social Security
checks
quote seniors are getting the biggest
increase in their Social Security checks
in 10 years through President Biden's
leadership that's a tweet from the White
House good news right this is talk about
it if you've got nothing else to
campaign on all right we're going to
give senior citizens a lot of money
people are very motivated about we're
just going to give you a lot of money
that's good news right well it would be
except for the fine print
except for the most magnificent fact
check in the history of social media
brought To Us by Elon Musk and Twitter
this is the context added when the White
House sent out that tweet quote seniors
will receive a large social security
benefit increase due to the annual cost
of living adjustment which is based on
the inflation rate that's not all so
they say the only reason you're getting
this big boost to your social security
check is because Joe Biden's inflation
is out of control but then it goes on to
say President Nixon in 1972 signed into
law automatic benefit adjustments tied
to the Consumer Price Index
so it no it's not that Joe Biden's just
giving you a lot of money he has to do
that because the inflation rate under
him is so bad and also it wasn't
Democrats who even set up that rule it
was the Republicans who set up that rule
just absolutely
devastating
the situation right now is so bad for
Democrats that Joe Biden can't even give
away money to likely voters without
reminding them what a crappy president
he is the whole thing was so
embarrassing that Biden deleted the
Tweet okay it's over it's over every
indicator suggests that the voters are
breaking
overwhelmingly for Republicans even
Democrat voters even in Democrats
strongholds and if the Democrats want to
stop the red tsunami that is approaching
they're going to need to do a serious
run around the sacred democracy
that they're always pretending to hold
dear I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday from Mark
and Nan who say when I was a kid and
during my first presidential election
you voted on election day one day period
And as I recall David Brinkley kept you
up to date on Election Day yes no but
that was that was back in the old
terrible days when we didn't have nearly
as well-functioning a democracy as we
have now that was back in the day where
you'd go on Election Day and cast your
votes and then figure out who won and
then you would have a great deal of
confidence in the Integrity of the
elections now however we're told a week
in advance oh you're not gonna have the
results on Election night no it's going
to take days it's going to take weeks
it's going to take
as long as it takes
to get enough Democrat ballots so that
the Republicans don't win too much
that's what's going to happen
that's what's going to happen so stay at
home don't even show up at the polls
just mail in your votes
one good thing you know about staying at
home you get to cook lots of really
really great food and when you need
propane for those grills for that turkey
fryer you got to check out cinch right
now go to cinch.com use promo code nulls
it is officially turkey frying season
and everyone is very excited of course
to break out that turkey fryer but
before you do it you got to call cinch
cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule no long-term commitment
or subscription required plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to be home to receive the delivery you
can track the order on the Cinch app
from anywhere are you looking to
exchange a tank cinch handles that whole
process for you so you don't have to go
to the hardware store or gas station you
can exchange any brand of tank as long
as it is a standard Grill size you
choose your delivery date and cinch
handles the rest go online to cinch.com
or download their app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Knolls go to cinch.com or download
the Sentry app use promo code Knowles to
get your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks
that is
c-ynch.com promo code Knowles this is a
limited time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it
cinch.com offer for details if you are
waiting for the Democrats to to finally
make one good argument for why voters
should elect them
you're just going to keep on waiting
okay I would not hold your breath for
that occurrence
Biden can't give away money he can't
even campaign on increasing Social
Security checks without it backfiring on
him then Biden comes out again we've got
what five days left now until the
midterms Biden comes at he says listen
I'm
well actually it's very it's very
difficult to interpret even what
argument he's making here
you know we're going to charge you I'm
making this up we're going to charge you
10 cents per an aspirin
and he said no we're only going to pay
five well we're not going to sell it
you're no problem they're going to lose
50 billion maps at aspirin or where the
hell they sell
point is they're going to have to
respond
I'm not just going to make fun of Joe
Biden being incoherent and his brain not
working I'm gonna I'm doing my best to
figure out what it is he's trying to say
we then you got 10 cents Jack come on
man you got wait hold on now and you
know I don't know what they sell they
sell aspirin or some whatever the hell
they sell we're gonna we're gonna buy it
10 cents come on Jack you know Corn Pop
bought
what what I think he is trying to say
here is that the Biden Administration
is going to negotiate
with big Pharma on behalf of the
American people I think that's the point
he was trying to make we're going to be
tough on big Pharma we're going to lower
drug prices we're going to stand up for
the people against big Pharma I think so
that that's certainly the most
charitable view of the gibberish that he
just came out with
but even on that does anyone believe
that does anyone believe right now you
got two parties the Republicans and the
Democrats which one is in the part which
one is in the pocket of big Pharma does
anyone seriously believe
that that it's the Republicans in the
pocket of big Pharma that the Democrats
are fighting big Pharma for the past
three years Democrats at every level of
government have have used all of their
energy in the entire force of the Law to
force you to pay big Pharma a bunch of
money and to inject yourself with a
dangerous experimental drug that came
out of big Pharma which was completely
protected from legal liability
and now we're supposed to believe hey
Jack I'm going to really take it to Big
Pharma no that's not true you're the
face of the covid regime bro
No One Believes that and then this is
not even some little side issue that
people aren't paying attention to you
shut down their world
unfortunately both parties were involved
in shutting down the world it was the
Democrats who insisted it remained shut
down it was the Democrats who insisted
that the schools remain shut down it was
the Democrats who insisted on mandating
the fauci ouchy the dangerous
experimental drug that people have had a
lot of problems because of or else you
lose your job that was the Biden
Administration mandate so now you're
going to look Us in the face and say
come on Jack I'm going to take on big
Pharma No One Believes that
even the point he's trying to make is
absurd and so last night Joe Biden had
the Hail Mary speech Joe Biden came out
he said I'm going to make a speech
defending democracy and
Joe Biden already tried this tactic he
tried that you know in front of the big
infernal red wall where he called half
the country fascists and you know was
gesticulating wildly and the speech did
not go well I got terrible terrible
reviews so because the Democrats have
nothing Joe Biden just tried it again he
tried the exact same speech half the
country's evil they're terrorists there
he didn't call us fascists this time per
se but he he insinuated that we're
fascists and he did call us a threat to
democracy the Aesthetics were much
better this time instead of the infernal
red you know gigantic backdrop it was
just a regular blue wall with some
American flags behind him but the speech
was substantively the same and it was a
speech not on any political issue
because all of those don't look very
good for the Democrats right now it was
on democracy
I know there's a lot of stake in these
midterm elections from our economy
the safety of our streets to our
personal freedoms the future of Health
Care Social Security Medicare it's all
important
but we'll have our differences we have
our difference of opinion and that's
what it's supposed to be
but there's something else at stake
democracy itself
I'm not the only one who sees it
recent polls have shown an overwhelming
majority of Americans
believe our democracy at is at risk that
our democracy is under threat
they too see that democracy is on the
ballot this year
and they're deeply concerned about it
so today
I appeal to all Americans regardless of
party to meet this moment of national
and generational importance
we must vote
knowing what's at stake and not just the
policy of the moment
democracy is on the ballot forget about
all those political issues you know
immigration the economy Health Care
education forget about all that because
we're terrible our record is terrible
and we're deeply unpopular on all of
that we Democrats but democracy is on
the ballot
so as I'm hearing him give this speech I
just keep asking myself
what does he think democracy is
I'm no political science PhD but last
time I checked democracy is what the
majority of people vote for
that's democracy that's all democracy is
it's what most people vote for when they
participate in their government
it's it's different than aristocracy
it's different than oligarchy it's
different than monarchy it's just that's
it's just what the people vote for
that's it so if the people want to elect
Republicans
and they go out and they vote for the
Republicans
that cannot be a threat to democracy
that would that necessarily by
definition is an expression of democracy
but Joe Biden doesn't seem to understand
that he goes on to give
his definition of democracy
for democracies are more than a form of
government
their way of being
a way of seeing the world
a way that defines Who We Are
what we believe why we do what we do
democracy is simply that fundamental
that's not true none of that is true
democracy actually just is a form of
government
that's all it is it's not a way of
seeing the world it's not an in ideology
exactly it's it's just a form of
government different than oligarchy well
now unfortunately our democracy seems to
be much closer to an oligarchy but
democracy itself is different than
oligarch it's different than monarchy
that's all it is what Joe Biden is
describing here is not democracy what he
is describing is liberalism liberalism
really is a way of viewing the world
liberalism really is an ideology
liberalism really is a kind of identity
a deep identity especially for these
people for the Liberals
but liberalism and democracy are
different
and I'm not the first to point it out
Adrian vermeul has made this point
Patrick Dineen has made this point a lot
of other people have made this point
when the Liberals say democracy they
mean liberalism that is why when the
people vote against them it cannot be
legitimate so I'm looking at the
elections now and I'm looking at how
Twitter is warning that the election is
going to take a really long time it's
going to take days and weeks to count
and you're getting you're hearing this
from the Pennsylvania Secretary of State
oh don't expect results on Election
night no it's going to take days and
weeks to get and I'm looking at all of
this and I'm saying oh they're
they're trying to rig it and they're
trying to rig it this is not some crazy
conspiracy theory the Democrats bragged
about rigging the 2020 election in Time
magazine in a very lengthy essay I
quoted it at length the other night
during a yaf speech at the University of
Kentucky but they brag about this stuff
how they changed all the rules how they
suppressed certain lawsuits to rig the
election in 2020. because they say we
have to rig tomorrow we have to save
democracy rather and so if democracy is
on the ballot then in their minds
they're justified in doing absolutely
anything they can up to and including
rigging the election so now we're in a
weird situation where
when conservatives win
the Liberals deny it because they don't
consider us legitimate participants in
our democracy when the Liberals win we
deny it because they rig the elections
and brag about it openly
so here we are nobody really believes
that the elections are legit anymore the
Democrats I think are much more at fault
about this they have been denying the
elections much longer than Republicans
have and which with much less reason
they deny the results of the 2000
election some deny the results of 2004
and objected to these elections the
woman who lost in 2016 denied the
results of that election Hillary Clinton
Stacey Abrams continues to deny the
results of the 2018 election okay it's
really it's really only 2020 where they
changed all the rules and admitted that
they rigged it that that the
conservative said hey this doesn't seem
like a totally legit election but either
way regardless I'm not even here just to
point fingers and cast blame regardless
here's where we are neither side
believes in the Integrity of the
elections and you've got Joe Biden
himself saying the election is
essentially only legit if we win because
we the Liberals are the only
supporters of democracy the Maga
Republicans which statistically means
all of the Republicans oppose the
Democracy so when they win it is by
definition illegitimate so here we are
the great Defenders of democracy are
saying that only they can win the great
Defenders of democracy Joe Biden and the
rest of them are saying if we don't have
one party Democratic liberal rule in
this country we no longer have our
traditional American system of
government those are the stakes and
they're going to keep counting those
freaking ballots until they get the
answer that they want if they have any
opportunity to do so
it was ironically a very very
anti-democracy speech and it was I'm not
going to subject you to the rest of the
stupid Joe Biden speech where he says
you know he talks about the attack by
the BLM loving gay pride waving nudist
hippie hemp Jeweler from Berkeley who is
a now apparently the most right-wing
Republican in America who went into the
Pelosi's home under very suspicious
circumstances and
there were all sorts of questions raised
by the dispatch call where Paul Pelosi
apparently knew the guy according to the
dispatch recording and said he was a
friend of his and knew him by name but
now they're saying he didn't know him at
all and the whole thing is stinks to
high heaven but
Joe Biden uses this
this whole apparent home invasion uh
right before the election to say that
the Republicans are terrorists and
insurrectionists I'm going to spare you
all that stupid stuff there was just one
line
that really drove me crazy because again
it seemed to step set the stage for
Democrats trying to rig this thing next
Tuesday
where he said look you can't only love
your country when you win
I've said before
you can't love your country only when
you win
this is no ordinary year
so I ask you to think long and hard
about the moment we're in really ironic
coming from the head of the Democrat
Party you'll remember infamously
Michelle Obama said in 2008 that the
first time in her adult life that she
was ever proud of her country was when
it elected her husband so she's saying
yeah I didn't like my country at all I
only like it when not only when we win
the Democrats but when I personally win
the Obama family gets to go to the White
House and and furthermore you see from
the Democrats in their rhetoric not only
do the Democrats only love their country
when they win they don't even seem to
love it then the Democrats don't love
America they don't they don't
I know you're not supposed to say that
but that's what that's what they say
when Barack Obama campaigns to
fundamentally transform America what
he's saying is I don't love America
because you don't want to fundamentally
transform things that you love you want
to fundamentally transform things that
you you don't love or at the very least
that you think are just so awful or in
just such a terrible state of disrepair
that there's nothing worth preserving
about them that you've got to
fundamentally
change it and Democrats have said this
for many Americans racist America is
awful it's bigoted it's terrible it's
imperialist it's this is It's that is
they hate it they hate the country they
want to radically change it and they
they are radically changing in system of
government the other irony about the
whole pro-democracy line here is that
the founding fathers hated democracy and
they the word democracy appears nowhere
in the Constitution if there's nowhere
in the Declaration of Independence it
does appear in The Federalist Papers
which explains the system of government
that the framers gave us and every
single time it appears in The Federalist
Papers it appears with disapproval the
framers and the founders hated democracy
they established a republic
where there is a distinction it's a
little bit of a nuanced distinction
between what a republic is and what a
democracy is and a lot of people are
dead certain that they know the exact
difference but I think the founding
fathers themselves were actually uh
somewhat contradictory on this topic
regardless what the effect of it was was
to give us a regime that had a lot of
different elements it had a kind of
monarchical element in the executive who
was strong it had a kind of aristocratic
element in the Senate and and other
political structures it obviously had a
strong Democratic element representation
for the people
we had checks and balances it was just a
kind of a mixed regime but the idea that
America was established as our sacred
democracy it's just completely made up
that's a retconning by by the Democrats
who ironically don't even like democracy
themselves but this is their line
they're sticking to it so Kareem
Jean-Pierre now got gets her marching
orders from the White House she says if
basically if you vote for the
Republicans you're voting against
democracy the president has long talked
about our nation being at an inflection
point
he has been clear democracy is under
assault and we cannot pretend otherwise
the president will continue to call
attention to the threat to democratic
integrity and to Public Safety posed by
those who deny the documented truth
about election result and those who seek
to undermine public faith in our system
of government
unfortunately we have seen mega mega
Republican officials who don't believe
in the rule of law
they refused to accept the results of
free and fair elections and they fan the
Flames of political violence through
what they praise and what they refuse to
condemn
it remains important for the president
to State strongly and unequivocally that
violence has no place in our democracy
the mega magger Republicans are an
existential threat to our democracy
because they deny the results of
elections they say that the elections
are stolen sometimes and that's the big
lie and that's why they're a threat to
democracy says Karine jump here the
White House Press Secretary
now on December 17 2016 here is what
green Jean Pierre said stolen emails
stolen drone stolen election
welcome to the world of unprecedented
unprecedented get it Trump
uh March 12 2019 this is what Korean
jump here had to say
the race
Stacey Abrams race in Georgia the race
was stolen okay
and then we have a reminder Brian Kemp
stole the gubernatorial election from
Georgians and Stacy Abrams
but the mega the mega mega Republicans
they're the the existential threat to
democracy because they uniquely deny the
results of elections right
not only are Republicans not unique in
questioning the results of elections we
do it probably one one thousandth of the
time that the Democrats do it's only a
problem when we do it
so what is this a hypocrisy from the
Democrats no to quote again that great
conservative law professor Adrian
vermeul it's not hypocrisy it's
hierarchy you see this in a story from
the New York Times I couldn't believe
this headline yesterday
black Faith leaders in Georgia speak out
against Herschel Walker
oh good they're speaking out social
Walker's really bad it's good that those
Faith leaders are speaking out
the pastor
Jamal Bryant delivered a fiery sermon on
Sunday denouncing Herschel Walker said
in 2022 we don't need a walker we need a
runner
it was an instance of black Faith
leaders in Georgia amplifying the
criticism of the Republican Senate
candidate now correct me if I'm wrong
I'm not a lawyer
isn't that illegal
isn't that illegal for churches which
have tax-exempt status to preach
politics from the pulpit because that's
what I was I was told that breaks
federal law
and actually I hear in the pages of of
outlets like the New York Times Like The
Washington Post like all the leftist
establishment media that this is an evil
terrible threat to America when those
pastors are are preaching against
the Democrats when they're preaching out
on politics
but you see
the the pastors the real pastors who
take Christianity seriously
they speak out against the left because
the left is essentially opposed to
Christianity in fact the left comes out
of an attack on the church that's where
the word comes from it comes from the
French Revolution people who sat on the
left of the National Assembly they were
the people who were attacking
specifically the church so real pastors
real Christians speak out against the
left okay and to put it as bluntly as I
possibly can and so the libs hate that
and so they always threaten to take away
the tax exam status of churches that do
that and they they always say it's a law
and they're going to prosecute these
people and all the rest but then when
the wolves in sheep's clothing the
wolves in Shepherd's clothing who from
the pulpit preach leftism
and and leave their flocks astray they
say this is a wonderful thing oh it's
it's just a great example of Faith
leaders
speaking out
but it's not it's not hypocrisy it is
hierarchy to quote vermul
they they don't care that yes they think
it's a double standard sure but they
don't think that that the left and the
right are comparable they don't think
that the the leftist pastors and the
right wing pastors are comparable they
don't think that the Biden voters and
the Trump voters are comparable
only the leftists are considered
legitimate to these people
and Biden has has said it himself
he said democracy is threatened by the
very existence of half the country
yes that's incoherent if you think that
by democracy he means democracy that's
not what he means he means liberalism
and if you contradict the libs there is
no limit
to the lengths that the libs will go to
boot you out of our political process
now you know tomorrow
very very exciting we will have the
voicemail bag
I love getting voicemail back uh come in
every single week and some people have
asked how do I submit a mailback
question they sometimes submit it
through my personal website I don't know
if it's going to go to the mailbox
that's not how you do it the way you do
it is you go to dailywire.com you go to
the Michael Knowles show page
and you say submit a mailbag question
then you can either type it in or if you
want your malefamous voice to be on air
you just record an audio file you can do
it on your phone you can do it on your
computer whatever app you use to record
audio files keep it to less than a
minute so that I can put it on air
please
I don't need your letter to the world
you know we don't need a full Manifesto
here we have limited time on the show
then attach that to the email send it in
I will get your beautiful voices
tomorrow on the show
you know that the Democrats are
desperate because they are they're
they're really scraping the bottom of
the barrel of who can give them any
energy going into the midterms
they're turning to Liz Cheney Liz Cheney
does Liz Cheney have a constituency
now her her State kicked her out of the
Republican party she got unceremoniously
booted out of Congress in Wyoming a
Cheney the Chinese are legends in
Wyoming a booted out there super
Republican plays Buddha right of
Congress
now she is backing Democrats pretty
left-wing Democrats and it's just a
reminder that it was never about Trump
Liz Cheney is backing Tim Ryan over JD
Vance in Ohio's U.S Senate race she says
I would not vote for JD Vance I would
vote for Tim Ryan if she were in Ohio
she's hitting the trail for the
Democrats now what we were told by the
Liz cheneys of the world and by her
supporters is this is just about Trump
trump is a unique threat to democracy oh
is it is JD Vance also a unique threat
to democracy now a lot of these people
are turning on Ron desantises Rhonda
Santos also a unique threat to democracy
these people all hate Ted Cruz is Ted
Cruz a unique threat to democracy that's
a lot of unique threats to democracy
because unique last time I checked I'm
no philologist but last time I checked
it means one
how come there's so many of these people
it was never it was never about Trump
it was always about
any threat to the liberal power
structure
and that's why you had people who would
vote with Republicans some of the times
when it didn't really matter
and they would take fairly conservative
positions sometimes Liz Cheney would
take fairly conservative positions
sometimes when it really didn't matter
you know you could vote really really
pro-life when Roe v Wade basically
gelded all pro-life legislation
you could vote for tough immigration
enforcement when there was never going
to be any immigration enforcement
whatsoever you could vote to get tough
on China when they knew that they were
never going to change the trade
relationship between the US and China
but then Trump comes in and he starts
actually doing these things
and he starts actually putting
pretty conservative justices on the
court
unlike George Bush who accidentally put
some conservative justices on the court
but tried to put liberal justices on the
court and did end up putting John
Roberts who's pretty liberal Justice on
the court
George W bush who talked a good game on
conservatism but he was basically for
open borders he was for wilsonian
adventurism around the world he was for
basically the kind of Clinton
global trade foreign policy it was just
all it wasn't a big
difference okay and that's what that's
what Liz Cheney is doing here and that's
what all these guys with the Lincoln
project is about that's
it's people who when they saw that we
could actually win they retreated back
to their masters they were treated back
to their real team which is the liberal
establishment
now Cheney
does not represent Republicans obviously
she does not represent people in Wyoming
obviously she doesn't represent women
either really great news coming out of
the Wall Street Journal one of the big
struggles for the GOP in recent years is
that Suburban white women moved Democrat
and they just they just didn't like
Trump they didn't like the tough talk I
don't know whatever it was they just
they they moved Democrats there are all
sorts of explanations as to why that was
I think that Trump actually got too much
blame for the for the move of suburban
white women out of the GOP but
regardless they're coming right back
into the Republican party now Suburban
white women have shifted 15 points in
favor of GOP control of Congress
this is a crucial
uh demographic
at the the move demonstrates a 27 point
move away from the Democrats since the
journals poll back in August so it
wasn't that long ago
and the white Suburban women consist uh
that they make up 20 of the electorate
so why is this the the Trump haters will
say that this is because Trump's not on
the ballot and so we're finally getting
the Suburban white women back
I don't think that's really the big
story here I think it's just crime I
think crime is the big story of the
midterm elections I think that the
Democrats for the past several years
have campaigned on defunding the police
and abolishing the police and letting
the criminals out of prison and normal
people hate that normal people of all
Races especially women
across the the fruited plains sea to
shining sea in America they hate it when
you let criminals out of prison
and they hate it when they have to fear
for their property and their lives and
the lives of their family
and I don't think it really has to do
with Trump at all
the other big story here Democrats put
all their eggs in the basket of abortion
they said look we're losing on the
economy and immigration foreign policy
and on and on and on but the one issue
we're going to run on now is that the
Supreme Court overruled Roe v Wade and
this is going to fire up women all
around the country and the women are
going to come out and vote for us and
we're going to stop the Red Wave and
we're actually maybe we'll even have a
Blue Wave we'll see what and then it
just didn't happen just didn't happen
and actually
it's not even just that you know the
women shifted
firmly to the Democrats but the men kind
of overwhelm them no no the women
shifted to the GOP they don't one the
pro-life movement is mostly women okay
and the pro-life issue it splits women
basically 50 50.
and the momentum is clearly on the side
of the pro-life movement but also just
poll after poll shows most people don't
vote on abortion even I I care about
abortion a lot I will vote on abortion
I'm part of 15 of the electorate that
does
you might care a lot about abortion you
are part of a very small portion of the
electorate that does and that 15
includes both the pro-abortion Fanatics
and the Defenders Of Life
so what is it seven and a half seven and
a half it's just it's so small the
Democrats just completely completely
miscalculated here both on crime and on
abortion and and far from seeing the the
GOP split
or the women vote split or anything like
that you're actually seeing it all come
together and you're seeing it come
together in a really crucial place in
Arizona so in Arizona Blake Masters is
running for the Senate against Mark
Kelly Mark Kelly is a rubber stamp for
Chuck Schumer and he's a Democrat but
he's got an interesting personal story
he's an astronaut his wife Gabby
Giffords was shot at a political event
and she had to leave Congress and then
he runs and he he enters the Senate and
so he's got a good personal story even
though he's an absolutely terrible
Senator Blake Masters is running in many
ways as an avatar of the new right he's
not just reciting all the same stupid
platitudes that we've heard for the last
15 years from the squishy loser
Republicans he's talking about real
things he thinks that the 2020 election
was stolen okay his words not mine don't
take me off YouTube but that's what he
thinks he says that in America it should
be a top priority of our politics to
make it to create the political
condition such that people can raise a
family on one income really really great
stuff talking in explicitly pro-family
to traditional conservative terms I
absolutely love that
on and on we've interviewed Blake on
this show I'm really supportive of his
campaign he he was
behind a little bit in the polls we'll
see it's going to be a real nail biter
but he got great news because the
libertarian candidate in that race Mark
Victor just dropped out and urged his
supporters to vote for Masters really
good news now
one thing that's unfortunate about the
way that the Democrats have rigged our
system in the last few years is that
they've taken election day and turned it
into election months in some cases
election two months there's widespread
mail-in votes so the question is how
many people have already voted for Mark
Victor
I don't know the exact rules in Arizona
so it might not be as bad as it is in
some states the other problem is Mark
Victor will be on the ballot so he
didn't drop out early enough to not be
on the ballot uh which is too bad that
would have helped Blake a lot more
but in any case good on Mark for for
dropping out
he says after a discussion with him I
believe it is in the best interests of
freedom and peace
to withdraw my candidacy and
enthusiastically support Black Masters
for U.S Senate I intend to assist in any
way reasonably possible to elect Blake
great line and that's how Republicans
should be thinking and not just
Republicans it's how moderates and even
Center life people should be thinking
think about the people who were on the
left
who in recent years seemed to be
supporting the Republicans more than the
Democrats I think about really prominent
people Joe Rogan
I think probably Bill Maher
I think about people like Elon Musk Elon
Musk was on the left for most of his
life he seems to be much more on the
right right now
normal people who say look I might not
agree with everything this candidate
wants I might not agree even with their
basic way of viewing the world but I
know that something is just really
really corrupt something is really
really wrong something is really really
incompetent about the Democrat party
it's a it's ironic that that the
Democrats are making this play right now
to say regardless of what you think
about the issues you've got to vote for
us because we're the Defenders of
democracy I think it's totally the
opposite I think it's the opposite in
reality and I think it's the opposite in
the perception of the people I think a
lot of people who don't like the
Republicans generally or who are not
don't consider themselves all that
conservative they're looking at the
system right now and they're saying wow
the Democrats pose a legitimate threat
to democracy they're rigging our
election system they're calling half the
country terrorists and fascists they're
sicking their Jack booted thugs on their
political opponents like Donald Trump at
Mar-A-Lago they're calling parents at
school boards domestic terrorists
they're trying to transgender our kids
against our will they're trying to
they're just they're such a threat to
our traditional way of life
such a threat to our rights such a
thread to our liberties
that we can't vote for the Democrats
we've got to vote for
the Republicans the collective leftist
meltdown
that I hope will occur on Election night
next week when they are voted out unless
they you know water main pipes break or
something is going to be glorious
they deserve everything that's coming to
them nothing will match it but I will
say a close second is everything rolling
out here at Daily wire plus episode two
of Jordan Peterson's new series on
marriage is out this episode is all
about negotiating or I should say
learning the proper way to negotiate
next is Candace owens's brand new
episode of her show taboo featuring
special guest and multi-platinum selling
musician Mia you will hear about her
rise to fame and being canceled for
speaking out about vaccine mandates
among other topics then there's Benjamin
Sunday special Ben sat down with
Tennessee governor Bill Lee to chat
about school choice fighting through
coveted policies his experiences on a
Women's Health Clinic board and more
last up tonight at seven
uh six o'clock Central daily wire plus
is releasing the documentary film my
dinner with Trump which is a behind the
curtain look at the former president and
his closest advisors as they dine
together at his private club in
Bedminster regardless of how you may
feel about the man this is Donald Trump
as the media would never show you
certainly nothing like this exists or
ever has existed on the right it's just
fabulous love him or hate him I promise
you you've never seen anything like it
so yes it's a big week around here if
you are not yet a member there's never
been a better time to join go to
dailywire.com Knowles to become a member
today
foreign
they're doing whatever they can
and it's still not enough Joe Biden just
announced a plan yesterday to pay for
heating bills for some people before the
midterms
Biden Administration announced six days
before the midterm elections that the
federal government will provide four and
a half billion dollars through the
Department of Health and Human Services
to quote help lower heating costs for
American families this winter and the
funds will cover unpaid Utility payments
and quote help families make
cost-effective home energy repairs to
lower their Heating and Cooling bills
okay again this is just like the Social
Security
payments
they think that this is a great headline
where hey we're going to give you a
bunch of money
but because we're talking about a topic
that is so basic why is everything so
expensive why is it expensive to go buy
groceries to go buy gas especially to
heat my home one because it's about
something that people are very very
familiar with at all
degrees of the political Spectrum
the question that this policy will raise
is
why are heating costs so high
do they have to do this
oh because of the stupid energy policies
of Joe Biden
don't forget gas prices are super high
right now they're double what they were
when I moved to Tennessee I moved to
Tennessee two years ago they're double
what they what they were
that's with Joe Biden releasing a
million barrels a day or out of the
Strategic oil Reserve
that's with Joe Biden emptying out our
strategic petroleum Reserve not totally
emptying it out but really depleting the
thing
and it still has had basically no effect
on the oil
markets
and the the effect that it has such that
it has brought prices down that's going
to end at the midterm elections and the
prices are going to go back up to what
they were it's just a disaster and a lot
of it's caused by the war in Ukraine the
war in Ukraine that essentially was
caused by Joe Biden as I've mentioned on
the show many times
and by shutting down the domestic energy
industry by saying no new oil and gas
lease is a no new oil pipelines and so
when people get their checks they might
say okay I'm glad you're paying for my
heating bills why can't I afford my own
heating bills to begin with Buster why
are you spending four and a half billion
dollars of my money by the way it's not
your money Joe Biden it's my money why
are you spending my money to subsidize
the heating bills that I used to be able
to afford that I can't afford anymore
because if you're stupid policies
speaking of inefficient ways to spend
money this story came up a couple of
days ago and
it horrified me you know that I'm not
much of a dog person
I'm not a cat person either but I'm not
I'm not really a dog person I'm a I'm a
people person
and this is so sad there's a restaurant
in San Francisco
that is now serving dogs filet mignon
in what is considered to be the first
Eatery designed only for dogs
this is not like you go to the cafe and
they have a little puppy bowl of water
and treats or whatever this is the
restaurant is only for dogs
it's called Doge d-o-g-u-e like Vogue
dog
and it launched in September in the
Mission District in San Francisco
and the meals include
several courses and they cost 75 dollars
per dog
I kid you not
costs more money to feed a dog at this
restaurant
then most people pay even at a nice
restaurant to go out and eat themselves
it does include a mimosa and a pastry
for the dog's owner but the real food is
for the dogs
the dog plates have items such as
chicken skin waffles filet mignon stick
tartar with quail egg oh that sounds
nice
and uh
some of the food you know is relatively
affordable it can get up to 95 dollars
why why is this happening
it's happening for one reason and one
reason only
it's because people are not having
children
and so they are treating their dogs as
their children
I'm not opposed to dogs I don't really
like them and I don't intend to get one
but I'm not opposed to dogs they're fine
in theory I like them in theory
but I really don't like dogs when the
dogs are treated like children
and and that's what has happened in our
society
people
people don't want to they think that
they don't want to have kids because
they think it's too much responsibility
anything it's too expensive and I think
they're not in a state in life where
they can then they'd have to make the
commitment to get married ideally and
you know it's just too much
responsibility and commitment man I'm
just going to start out I'm just going
to get a dog
it's the same thinking that as people
say I don't want to get married right
away maybe I'll just move in with my
girlfriend you know just kind of it's a
lesser step I can get out whenever I
want less responsibility you can't you
know take a you can't take a kid to the
shelter you're not really supposed to
you can't take a dog to the shelter if
it's too much so I'm going to do that
and that'll be a lot easier but the the
practical effect of that
is you don't have less responsibility
really people treat their dogs like
children they spend every bit of time
that they would spend on children they
just Channel all that time toward their
dogs I know people who get babysitters
for their dogs to come over for their
homes when they go away and sit with the
dog for days on end and spend all sorts
of money on the dog's vet and The
Grooming and the food and the filet
mignon and everything okay
and this is what they think about
cohabitation they say well I'm just
going to move in but then it's not as
much of a commitment it's not not going
to be as intense as getting married but
it is just as intense you know you are
living with this person you you're very
often putting the same amount of energy
and emotional investment and money even
into that you're just not getting the
fruits of it
so you're putting all the same amount of
money and and time and Care into your
dog but you the dog's not going to take
care of you in your old age you're not
going to see your smile reflected on the
face of the dog
you're not going to get little doggy
grandchildren someday you're not going
to get to go to your doggies ballet
recital
you're not and even now it's really sad
people will take their dogs to Doggy
Daycare and they'll get little
certificates for your doggy completed
this task or your doggy jumped through
the hoop today and they so you you just
can't deny your human longings and so
what people are doing is they're not
avoiding that emotional and financial
expenditure they're just putting it in a
in a dead end place
same thing with with cohabitation you're
not avoiding the financial and emotional
expenditure you're just putting it into
a place where there's much less
stability where the whole thing could
fall apart where it's not designed to
grow and grow your family and grow your
life and people just
people just need to grow up and save the
filet mignon for the adult Save The
Flaming yone and the quail eggs for me
okay because I can appreciate it much
more than a dog
and stop use you're not you're not going
to avoid you're not going to avoid
civilization and Society you're not
going to avoid
the way that that life has been lived
for Millennia okay we think that we in
the Modern Age we think that everything
that came before us was really dumb and
stupid and we figured it out sometime in
the mid 1960s we figured it out that all
the people that came before us were dumb
idiots and they were totally wrong and
we've reinvented the wheel and we're
just so smart
and we can avoid all of the Eternal
questions and natural longings of human
beings and it's not true
it's not true and the more we deviate
from the wisdom of the ages and the more
we we Channel our our desires into
bizarre places the less fulfilled we're
going to be
stop it give your dog a bone and you eat
the filet mignon
now rhymes speaking of
seething I'm seething it drives me crazy
I hate I hate the dogs as children stuff
it drives me insane
speaking of people seething the Liberals
are seething
over
Elon Musk taking their blue check
privileges away well he's actually not
taking their blue check privileges away
he's just going to charge them eight
dollars a month for it
and you can tell it's all the art of the
deal stuff he first he comes out he says
I'm going to fire three quarters of the
staff and everyone freaks out about that
and he's probably gonna fire a much
lower number but whatever he fires it'll
seem like a compromise because he
started out at this insane negotiating
position so he opened up he said I'm
going to charge people 20 bucks a month
for their blue checks
then everyone freaked out about it and
he said okay it'll only be eight bucks a
month but that was probably his number
to begin with and he says I'm gonna
charge you eight bucks a month if you
want to keep your blue check if you want
to get special privileges with your blue
check because uh I'm I'm going to
democratize the blue checks and AOC in
particular lost it she goes LMAO at a
billionaire earnestly trying to sell
people on the idea that free speech is
actually an eight dollar a month
subscription plan
Elon Musk just I love the Elon Musk AOC
dynamic
where he'll say hey stop flirting with
me come on I'm shy don't hey come on any
so your response here he goes your
feedback's appreciated now pay eight
dollars
because it's not he's not charging eight
dollars for free speech he's charging
eight dollars for what he's referred to
as the Lords and peasants model of
Twitter that has prevailed until now
which is that if you're on Twitter and
you have a blue check I I am one of the
the Blessed few who has a blue check and
it's true you get Amplified a lot more
you you have a much wider reach it's
considered not just a way to verify your
identity which is what it was supposed
to be but it's considered a mark of
prestige which this is why it was really
strange back when uh in 2016 or 2017 the
Liberals took away Richard Spencer the
white identitarian political activist
they took away his blue check mark his
verification badge
well if it's a verification badge why
would they take it away did he stop
being Richard Spencer no they took it
away because they knew that it was a
mark of prestige and they wanted to take
that Prestige away from him and so Elon
Musk is coming in and saying everyone
should get The Prestige
and the Liberals the Democrats
ironically they say no we don't want
that
is it about the eight bucks Elon also
replied to AOC with a picture from her
campaign website where she is selling a
purple sweatshirt just a cheap
purple sweatshirt for 58 dollars he's
like is eight dollars so hard for you
also AOC drove a Tesla I don't know if
she still does but she the woman
famously owned a Tesla okay so she's
doing very well and she clearly likes
Elon musk's products
but it's it in a way it is just a
perfect representation of the stakes in
this election which is the Democrats are
telling you that if you don't support
them you hate democracy meanwhile they
do everything they possibly can to
undermine democracy
whether we're talking about trade deals
whether we're talking about immigration
whether we're talking about election day
or whether we're talking about your blue
check mark on Twitter
Democrats are the party of oligarchy
maybe they always were
they certainly are now the Republicans
are the party of democracy
For Better or For Worse that's the
situation that we are in right now and
many people have perceived that and
that's why people who not that long ago
would have called themselves Democrats
and who really care about democracy and
they and their anti-establishment it's
why they are flocking in droves to the
Republicans it's why the Democrats are
trying so hard to suppress their votes
now I don't know very much about polling
so I'm going to invite on a master
pollster Robert kahele to tell me what I
should know going into midterm elections
the rest of the show is continuing now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]